nos piden que simplificamos 48 entre 64
a su mínima expresión 48 entre 64 y
bueno si estoy diciendo que 48 entre 64
es una fracción entonces su numeradores
48 y su denominador es 64 y podemos ver
este 64 tal vez como un todo si nosotros
tenemos por ejemplo aquí un todo
se me ocurre que sea un todo de una
barra de dulce imaginad que esta es una
barra de dulce que es tu todo y si esta
barra es mi todo que son 64 pedazos y no
voy a dividir los 64 pedazos porque tú
no vas a ver ninguno de los pedacitos
además de que me tardaría mucho en
hacerlo pero esta es una barra de dulce
que estructurado y está dividida entre
64 pedazos y si yo me tomo 48 de estos
pedazos me quedaría más o menos como por
aquí
imagínate que todos estos son los 48
pedazos de estos 64 que tenemos de este
todo
barra del dulce ok entonces imagínate
que estos son los 48 pedazos ahora sí
nosotros escribimos 48 364 justo aquí
48 ya esto lo estamos dividiendo
dividiendo entre 64 esta fracción de
aquí y yo lo que quiero es encontrar
esta fracción en su misma expresión y
justo ahorita voy a hablar en su mínima
expresión lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que a estos 48 de 64 tal vez
lo podamos dividir en grupos que sea
mucho más fácil tomarlo en lugar de
dividir todo esto en 64 partes y para
esto lo que se me ocurre es encontrar el
máximo común divisor entre 48 y 64 y si
no sabemos cuál es el máximo común
divisor entre estos 2
imagínate que tenemos aquí a todos los
factores de 48 ya todos los factores 64
y el que se me ocurra que es el más
grande de todos ellos que puedes dividir
a los dos es 16 entonces si yo divido 48
entre 16 esto va a ser lo mismo
déjame poner con este color esto hace lo
mismo
48 no puedo ver como 3 veces 16 3 por 16
mientras que 64 lo puedo ver como 4
veces 16 esto es lo mismo que 4 por 16 4
por 16 ok esto está diciendo que si
nosotros tenemos 64 partes lo podemos
dividir en grupos de 16 y 48 es lo mismo
que tres grupos de 16 así que imagínate
que de aquí me tomo un grupo de ellos un
grupo de ellos es de aquí este de aquí
va a tener 16 pedazos 16 pedazos aquí no
voy a tomar otro de ellos otro de ellos
va a ser este de aquí ok y esto también
va a tener 16 pedazos y aquí me voy a
tomar el último de ellos que también va
a tener 16 pedazos de estos 64 ahora 64
es exactamente lo mismo que 4 por 16 así
que en lugar de ver 64 pedazos justo
aquí voy a dividirlo en cuatro pedazos
en cuatro partes de 16 cada uno y
entonces aquí tendría la primera
esto sería un grupo de 16 aquí tengo
otra de ellas otra parte otro grupo de 6
justos le habíamos dicho hace rato aquí
tengo la otra de ellas y mediante que
cada una de ellas tiene el mismo grosor
16 y por último quedaría esta parte de
ellas que también tiene 16 y bueno estoy
pensando que cada uno de los cuadrados
que tengo aquí tienen la misma longitud
ahora si es 48 entre 64 es lo mismo que
3 por 16 entre 4.16 esto lo puedo
escribir como tres cuartos si te das
cuenta lo que tenemos de color rosa son
tres pedazos uno fíjate bien aquí tengo
uno de ellos uno de ellos dos de ellos
dos de ellos y aquí tengo el tercero de
ellos tres pedazos tengo tres pedazos de
estos cuatro totales de estos cuatro
totales porque éste no está coloreado
tres pedazos de 4
ahora si nosotros queremos llegar a esta
igualdad de una manera matemática
podremos pensar en lo siguiente esto es
lo mismo que tener a 48 entre entre 64
en 34 y esto es exactamente lo mismo que
decir a que tengo tres por 16 voy a
ponerlo justo aquí esto es 3 por 16 y
esto dividido entre 4 por 16 esto
dividido entre 4 por 16 y si te das
cuenta aquí tengo 16 entre 16 lo cual es
1 estos dos los voy a cancelar porque me
dan 116 entre 16 y simple y
sencillamente me quedaría con 3 sobre 4
con 3
con tres sobre cuatro tres cuartos que
es justo lo que llegamos tenemos tres
partes coloreadas de estas cuatro
totales
ahora si tú no supieras que el máximo
común divisor entre 48 y 64 es 16
podemos tomarnos aquí el 48 sobre 64
déjame ponerlo con este color
48 entre 64 entre 64 y de aquí partir y
empezar a decir bueno también yo puedo
dividir el 48 y es de 4 ambos
simultáneamente entre un mismo número y
se me ocurre que si lo primero que
podemos pensar es que estos dos tienen
mitad entonces qué te parece si divido
la parte de arriba entre 2 y lo mismo
que voy a hacer arriba lo voy a hacer
abajo para que no se altere nuestra
fracción entonces voy a dividir esta
parte entre dos y esto va a ser igual a
48 entre 2 es lo mismo que 24 24 entre
60 y 64 entre 2 lo cual es 30
y dos de lujo y tal vez se nos ocurra
que estos 210 mitad pero también
podríamos tomar los otro número se me
ocurre que el número que puede dividir a
estos dos es 4 por ejemplo entonces
puedo dividir entre 4 la parte de arriba
y para no alterar esta fracción voy a
dividir entre 4 también la parte de
abajo y vamos a ver que nos quede de
manera exacta y si yo divido 24 entre 4
esto es lo mismo que 6 entre 32 entre 4
lo cual es 8 y en este momento tal vez
podría pensar que ya llegué a la misma
expresión sin embargo si me fijo
detenidamente en seis octavos me voy a
dar cuenta que todavía hay otro número
que los divide en los dos
simultáneamente de hecho es otra vez el
2 tanto el 6 como el 8 tienen mitad otra
vez y entonces la vamos a dividir la
parte de arriba entre 2 y vamos a
dividir la parte de abajo entre 2 para
no alterar esta fracción y me va a
quedar que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 6 entre 2 lo cual es 3
/ a 8 entre 2 lo cual es 4 entre 4 ahora
lo que quiero que veas es que tres
cuartos ya es la fracción que representa
la misma expresión de esta que ahora que
empezamos 48 entre 64 y la razón es que
tanto 3 como 4 ya no son divisibles
entre un mismo número y justo en ese
momento cuando ya no existe ese número
es que tenemos la mínima expresión de
una fracción que en este caso es tres
cuartos recuerda que ya llegaste a su
mínima expresión cuando el 3 y el 4 otra
manera de verlo es que su máximo factor
común es 1 ahora nosotros podemos
empezar con 48 y 64 buscar el máximo
común divisor y ver que es 16 y dividir
48 entre 16 lo cual no va a dar 3 64
entre 16 lo cual me va a dar 4 y decir
que realmente lo que estamos haciendo es
tener todo esté entero completo esta
barra de dulce y dividirla en pedazos de
16 16 16 16 16
y entonces me voy a dar cuenta que cada
uno de los pedazos va a crear un pedazo
mucho más grande que son estos pedazos
que estoy tomando es de aquí este y este
lo cual le va a dar tres pedazos de
color rosa de los cuatro totales uno dos
tres cuatro y es justo por eso que
podemos decir que 48 entre 64 se puede
simplificar en su misma expresión como
tres cuartos